con nuestro primer invitado el día
hablamos del presidente venezolano
Nicolás Maduro que recupera posiciones
en escena internacional la llegada de
Gustavo Petro a Colombia y las
conversaciones con Washington
presionadas por el lobby de las
petroleras para flexibilizar a sanciones
y también reactivar la producción local
permiten al gobierno reposicionarse en
la región al gobierno del presidente
Nicolás Maduro saludamos a nuestro
invitado
Hola investigadora escrito del
observatorio venezolano de la
Universidad del Rosario y presidente de
la asociación diálogo ciudadano Colombo
venezolano cio Mil gracias por estar con
nosotros esta mañana viernes en directo
América de trans24 es un placer estar
con ustedes Raúl Cómo podemos si omin
leer este regreso digamos paulatino pero
que cada vez se hace más evidente del
presidente Nicolás madura toda la escena
internacional recordemos Que
prácticamente toda la comunidad
occidental no lo reconoció por un buen
tiempo desde 2019 cuando reconocían al
líder opositor Juan guaidó Juan guaidó
Parece que ya pasó a la historia y
solamente hay un líder en Venezuela
Nicolás Maduro Sí bueno como tú dices
Bueno un regreso paulatino pero yo
añadiría tener que muy condicionado No
no es un regreso así estelar ni nada por
el estilo No creo que en esto influyen
muchas cosas influye por un lado
indudablemente el tema de la guerra en
Ucrania que un poco Pues quizá ha hecho
que Estados Unidos y quizás algunos
países europeos Pues también estén
buscando no a corto plazo sino mediano y
largo plazo a Venezuela como un eventual
proveedor digamos energético petrolero a
corto plazo no porque Venezuela no tiene
posibilidades a corto plazo de hacer de
suplir digamos una demanda importante de
petróleo en el mundo pero quizá Esto
está influyendo pero también Bueno creo
que están influyendo indudablemente Pues
las negociaciones que se vienen
adelantando a trompicones porque en el
pasado sabemos que no han tenido mayor
éxito Pero bueno se reanudaron
recientemente y creo que Estados Unidos
principalmente pero también Creo que con
el apoyo de otros países occidentales y
añadiría también con con el apoyo de de
varios países latinoamericanos que hoy
están digamos controlados por gobiernos
de izquierda de diversas índole pero que
creo que tampoco tienen una solidaridad
automática con el régimen maduro sino
que están tratando de incidir también
para que de alguna manera haya alguna
pues salida democrática a Venezuela
claro y estos países digamos que de
alguna manera u otra sesión necesitan a
Venezuela por muchas razones hablamos de
evidentemente el gobierno colombiano con
la llegada de Gustavo Petro al poder y
también la reelección de Lula en Brasil
que vuelve a ser presidente de ese país
luego de varios años no Entonces qué
lectura también le podemos dar
a esta situación en nuestra región Bueno
yo creo que a Colombia en primer lugar
le interesa también tener estabilidad en
la región No si por muchas razones para
el propio éxito del plan estrella de de
Petro que es el el plan de la paz Total
no de buscar una una pastolla mucho más
amplia de la que se ya se había digamos
alcanzado con el acuerdo con las con las
Farc pero también vemos que hay
posiciones muy diferentes por ejemplo
borica tenía una posición de
enfrentamiento con el siendo un gobierno
izquierda de enfrentamiento bastante
fuerte con el gobierno de de maduro ha
criticado el tema de los Derechos
Humanos muy muy claramente y la falta de
democracia en el país Petro ha sido más
cuidadoso en esto porque bueno Tiene
muchos más interés también en juego un
país fronterizo con mucha migración
venezolana también pero ha tenido
también algunas posiciones digamos en la
campaña no calificó dictadura al régimen
de maduro y hoy en día pues le ha
ofrecido al régimen de Maduro que vuelva
a la al sistema interamericano de
derecho humanos que vuelva al al al al
pacto al pacto andino entonces creo que
está buscando alguna manera también que
se tranquilice un poco las cosas en la
región porque él necesita También
necesita estabilidad para el propio
éxito de su de su plan de gobierno y
tenerte en un comercio fronterizo más
más importantes que hay del que hay en
la actualidad no vamos a ver qué pasa
con Lula que es un actor de Mucho peso y
muy importante en el pasado digamos que
Lula Pues tuvo pues una amistad política
importante con con Hugo Chávez pero yo
creo que las circunstancias han cambiado
en Brasil han cambiado en el mundo yo me
imagino que que Lula también se sumará a
estos países digamos de de América
Latina que van a tratar de buscar una
una salida democrática en en Venezuela Y
quizá pocos algunas afinidades que a ver
del punto de vista ideológico igual
pueden ayudar también a a abrir ese
camino no vamos a ver no no podemos
asegurar nada tampoco este este
empoderamiento de Nicolás maduro en
escena internacional debilita aún más ya
la fragmentada o posiciones venezolana
cómo queda la posición dentro de
Venezuela con todo esto que está
ocurriendo bueno no creo que la No creo
que especialmente la debilite Sí yo creo
que que están produciéndose algunos
digamos algunos desarrollos en paralelo
el tema de las negociaciones creo que es
importante y no creo que la No creo que
las negociaciones que se están llevando
a cabo debiliten a la oposición Más bien
yo creo que le dan fuerza si el acuerdo
que se llegó recientemente que fue el
acuerdo social creo que fue un digamos
fue un ejercicio digamos de madurez
política por por todas las partes para
hacer para ser justo y no creo que esto
particularmente la No creo que la
debilite más bien en la medida en que el
acuerdo en
avancen creo que eso puede dar
esperanzas digamos el pueblo venezolano
en general y esto más bien Podría más
bien fortalecer ya la la oposición que
está efectivamente muy dividida y viene
está en un momento digamos de reflujo
político por no haber alcanzado digamos
los objetivos políticos que se había
trazado viene trabajando por ejemplo en
las primarias de para conseguir un
candidato único en las elecciones de
2024 y se está trabajando muy muy
seriamente al respecto y creo que esta
es un aspecto Más allá de que está en un
momento difícil creo que está está dando
pasos también para avanzar rápidamente
es una pregunta creo que difícil de
contestar pero por qué en estos 20 años
ya no de de Hugo Chávez luego ya de
Nicolás maduro digamos el mismo el mismo
sistema en Venezuela
Por qué la posición no ha podido
Y por qué la posición parece siempre
como debilitada y y realmente no ha
podido ganar el terreno que que
necesitan para un cambio de política en
Venezuela Bueno yo creo que en primer
lugar es porque el gobierno de maduro ha
sido un gobierno que ha derivado hacia
un sistema dictatorial no y ha ejercido
pues eh No ha jugado limpio ha ejercido
una represión muy grande y eso
indudablemente tiene una incidencia muy
importante esto en primer lugar también
creo que por parte de la oposición ha
habido ha habido también equivocaciones
ha habido división también y por
supuesto eso Tampoco tampoco ayuda Así
es de parte y parte de una manera pero
tampoco yo lo que creo que no lo que no
debemos olvidar que es un gobierno Pues
de carácter dictatorial y y que eso
Bueno pues tiene como decimos se dice
popularmente tiene el sartén agarrado
por el mango no y es muy difícil tener
esas circunstancias pues actuar
con exiliados con gente presa con
tortura no con con todo tipo de
triquiñuelas para no permitir que la
vida política de un país se desarrolle
digamos adecuadamente